In equilibrium, we had to have a zero rate of change.
The temperature should be staying constant so there's three candidates.
The middle one is a little tricky. Actually, our function never becomes zero.
It jumps, but even if it was continuous, this point would constitute an unstable equilibrium.
If we are below the temperature of ignition, there is no fire and we simply lose heat
and if we are above the temperature of ignition, there is fire and we gain heat.
This point would be unstable anyway. The lower equilibrium is stable.
If we are below the ambient temperature, we gain heat from the environment.
If we are above the ambient temperature, we lose heat at the environment. So no problem.
This is stable and the upper one is stable as well. Here we have combustion.
Combustion is going on.
If the temperature was a little lower, the rate of change of the temperature
would be positive--it would be moving up.
If the temperature was a little higher, the rate of change would be negative--we're moving down,
meaning at this point, we lose as much heat to the environment as we gain from combustion.
The answer is there's two stable equilibria.